the Army families around 18 in number
living on this former Air Base in Essex
thought they would have until the end of
the summer before having to leave the
site is being repurposed to house Asylum
Seekers
it's rare for military families to speak
out but such is the level of frustration
felt within the community a member of
one of the families living on the base
has agreed to speak to Sky News
anonymously we've revoiced their words
originally we were given a good time
period it was a good couple of months
period but over the last few weeks
that's all shuffled and we've almost
been moved off the base now before the
Asylum Seekers move on
for some families it's a week's notice
it's obviously quite hard for them
they're having to pack their whole lives
up in a week
and how do people feel about that
stressed
stress sums up perfectly
the phrase I'd like to use probably
contains a swear word I think
appalled
appalled is probably the nicer way to
say it let down
they've railroaded everyone with this
they haven't listened to us
they don't want to listen
Sky News understands the home office
plans to move the first Asylum Seekers
to the site this summer
nothing's happened on this base for
probably 10 years and now all of a
sudden it is just constant work and
they're rushing now
from the front gate at the base you can
see the contractors busily coming and
going the government needs to be seen to
be tackling the migration crisis and
that involves moving Asylum Seekers to
large accommodation sites like this and
away from costly hotels in towns and
cities
but locals sharing these photos of
attempts to deliver Porter cabins
through the narrow Lanes say their rural
location isn't the answer
the nearest Village a mile from the base
has a population of 700 the government
wants to move 1700 Asylum Seekers to the
area
I think if you put
I think end of 2 000 people up on that
base with no money and nothing to do
whoever they were worried if they were
trainee Vickers I think you could well
have problems I think it's only human
nature people get bored
they start looking for something to do
and that's something to do with a
proportion of people whoever they are
May well involve some sort of Mischief
the home office says it's been closely
engaging with families on the base and
they will all be moved to brand new
homes Lisa Holland Sky News Essex